[Music]
war and peace a tone a slog the sort of
book you shouldn't read in bed because
if you fall asleep it could give you a
concussion right only partly Warren
peace is a long book sure but it's also
a thrilling examination of history
populated with some of the deepest most
realistic characters you'll find
anywhere and if its length intimidates
you just imagine how poor Tolstoy felt
in 1863 he set out to write a short
novel about a political dissident
returning from exile in Siberia five
years later he had produced a twelve
hundred page epic featuring love stories
battlefields bankruptcies firing squads
religious visions the burning of Moscow
and a semi domesticated pair but no
exile and no political dissidents here's
how it happened Tolstoy a volcanic soul
was born to a famously eccentric
aristocratic family in 1828 by the time
he was 30 he had already dropped out of
Kazan University gambled away the family
fortune joined the army written memoirs
and rejected the literary establishment
to travel Europe he then settled into
Yasnaya Polyana his ancestral mansion to
write about the return of the
Decembrists a band of well born
revolutionaries pardoned in 1856 after
30 years in exile but Tolstoy thought
how could he tell the story of the
Decembrists returned from exile without
telling the story of 1825 when they
revolted against the Conservatives our
Nicholas the first and how could he do
that without telling the story of 1812
when Napoleon's disastrous invasion of
Russia helped trigger the
authoritarianism the Decembrists were
rebelling against and how could he tell
the story of 1812 without talking about
1805 when the Russians first learned of
the threat Napoleon posed after their
defeat at the battle of Austerlitz
so Tolstoy began writing both about the
big events of history and the small
lives that inhabit those events he
focused on aristocrats the class he knew
best
only occasionally touches on the lives
of the vast majority of the Russian
population who were peasants or even
serfs farmers bound to serve the owners
of the land on which they lived
war and peace opens on the eve of war
between France and Russia aristocrats at
a cocktail party fret about the looming
violence but then changed the topic to
those things aristocrats always seem to
care about money sex and death this
first scene is indicative of the way the
book bounces between the political and
personal over an ever widening canvass
there are no main characters in war and
peace instead readers enter a vast
interlocking web of relationships and
questions will the hapless and
illegitimate son of a count marry a
beautiful but conniving princess will
his only friend survive the battlefields
of Austria and what about that nice
young girl falling in love with both men
at once real historical figures mix and
mingle with all these fictional folk
Napoleon appears several times and even
one of Tolstoy his ancestors plays a
background part but while the characters
and their psychologies are gripping
Tolstoy is not afraid to interrupt the
narrative to pose insightful questions
about history why do Wars start what are
good battlefield tactics do nations rise
and fall on the actions of so-called
great men like Napoleon or are there
larger cultural and economic forces at
play these extended digressions are part
of what make war and peace so panoramic
and scope but for some 19th century
critics this meant war and peace barely
felt like a novel at all it was a large
loose baggy monster in the words of
Henry James Tolstoy in fact agreed to
him novels were a Western European form
Russian writers had to write differently
because Russian people lived differently
what is war and peace he asked it is not
a novel still less an epic poem still
less a historical chronicle war and
peace is what the author want
and was able to express in the form in
which it was expressed it is in other
words the sum total of Tolstoy
imaginative powers and nothing less by
the time war and peace ends Tolstoy has
brought his characters to the year 1820
36 years before the events he originally
hoped to write about in trying to
understand his own times he had become
immersed in the years piled up behind
him the result is a grand interrogation
into history culture philosophy
psychology and the human response to war
[Music]